I'm just gonna show you three quick
questions under this heading which is
the last of my explanation sort of
depending on how well or badly you can
want this test is afternoon basically
the question I got asked just as people
running out of the class yesterday okay
so when it says publish time with
derivatives it's usually any questions
to do with iterate this or evaluate that
or solve this and they say by
differentiating this well they say it
differentiates some brain of thing and
hits work this out which is something
upon which is I'm gonna have to do it
okay
so for instance they say I'll
differentiate that be the question I got
was XP DX and I could do that but I'm
gonna do them I'm gonna do X sine X just
because it's you know from the head you
retreat differentiate X sine X and hence
by the integral all I think it's X cos x
yeah the integral of X cos x okay you
can see is some kind of relationship
here the question is just how do you get
there so this is a product this
appreciate what I do well first do I
need to wrap my you in my V you guys
reckon you could do without them let's
do it without my hardcore I have a
friend and the easiest way to get him to
do something is to say I bet you can't
and then I sure can alright so be you -
right which is sine X is my V and my new
- is just one so I'm just gonna leave it
offer plus UV - so X and he's made the
closet okay so remember our question was
what's the integral all up here
what's the integral of x cos x
okay sir probably gonna get it from what
I've got well you can see I'm a three
terms here and just like we can never
save the implicit differentiation you
differentiate everything with respect to
X so this is the reverse process I'm
going to integrate every single term
with respect to X now whatever this is
is the derivative X sine X so when I
integrate it I'm gonna go back right so
I guess I'm an X sine X and cuz I
integrated and it's indefinite okay I
was gonna have my constant flying around
there as well so I've integrated the
left-hand side now what happens on the
right-hand side I'm just gonna do it
longhand so you see exactly what I'm
doing
integrate this term and then I integrate
this okay so you can see what I'm after
is this last term in the equation so
that's what I'm gonna make this object
okay but before I do that but it's just
evaluate the integral of sine X with a
sine X come from it comes from negative
cos right good so now this is slightly
naughty but I think you're getting away
with it really because I'm integrating I
should have a constant here right
however I've already got a constant and
a constant minus another closet is it's
still just another closely if you wanna
be really really technically correct
well number one we should have said that
C is a constant so should have said that
okay but then yeah because there's
another closet I'm gonna sort of combine
it with the other one if you want to be
really technical you can just make a
different conflict okay where D is also
just a different one okay all right so
there's negative cos I've taken care of
the constant than the other there's my
integral the one I'm actually after okay
so you can see all I need to do now is
just make up the subject
so